investigators in Colorado believed they
found the bodies of a pregnant mother
and her two young daughters allegedly
murdered by their father Chris Watson
made his first court appearance
yesterday as the sole suspect in the
case he will likely face three counts of
murder in the first degree and three
counts of tampering with evidence
Omar Villafranca has outside the
family's home in Frederick Colorado
Omar good morning good morning the
memorial is growing in front of the
Watts house prosecutors think that the
mother and the two daughters were killed
inside this home and that has friends
and neighbors in this area shocked those
two little girls are so innocent and so
sweet
and I just don't understand how you
could do this to your family
Ashleigh Belle's daughter played with
Shannon Watts four-year-old Bella and
three year old Celeste Belle's memories
of the seemingly close-knit Colorado
family are now shattered I kept telling
myself no no no he wouldn't do anything
to her Chris Watts
said little inside a Colorado courtroom
on Thursday the silence was a dramatic
reversal from earlier in the week as
Watts pleaded for his family's safe
return I was want them to come back and
if they're not safe right now that's
what's that's what's tearing me apart
Thursday police recovered a body
believed to be Shannon's on an oil field
where her husband worked bodies believed
to be Bella and Celeste were also found
in close proximity to their mother Watts
was fired Wednesday the same day of his
arrest investigators have not revealed a
possible motive
we love Schmidt friends Nicholas and
Amanda Thayer say that Shannon expressed
concerns of infidelity it came to her
mind that possibly he could be cheating
as horrible as this outcome is our role
now is to do everything that we can to
determine exactly what occurred and
assist and
a federal case Shannon's family in North
Carolina is running the gamut of
emotions they're confused and they're
angry over this tragedy police are not
commenting on reports that Chris
confessed to killing his wife and two
daughters but he is expected to be
formally charged on Monday no Mara
thanks